We were put
out, of course, on Hurricane Ian.
But here's something
you didn't really hear about.
When the storm
smashed into central Florida.
It took out hundreds of thousand
be colonies
and wiped out
a vital link in our food chain.
Well, now beekeepers are still s
from these losses.
Our Bill Weir met with some of t
and he joins us now.
I never thought about this Me ne
However, I know bees are very im
to the whole ecosystem more than
When we talk about
when you have the birds
and the bees talk,
it's takes on a whole new import
now because one out
of every three bites of food
is courtesy of a pollinator like
that fly.
And they are in deep trouble
as a result of sort of colliding
climate crises.
I went down to Arcadia, Florida,
to get a state of things.
These guys know the state of agr
better than ever.
Anyone, really,
and fewer sadder and more worrie
Now you got to get a handful of
Really? Yeah. Okay.
I'm not usually in the habit
of accepting a handful
of stinging insects,
but Keith Council has a 40 year
professional relationship with h
and you never, rarely
wear a veil or gloves or anythin
Don't really need to.
And these days,
they need all the love they can
Hurricane Ian arrived at the wor
possible time for this business,
just as beekeepers from around
the country
were set up to catch the autumn
of the Brazilian pepper tree.
The yard went under
the storm drought and crushed
hundreds of thousands of hives.
Killing countless millions of be
It's going to come back.
All right. Nothing left.
You could actually see a water l
where it came up to here.
And because Ian blew away
so much vegetation,
those that survived are starving
Some of these bees
have gotten three shots of feed,
and that's a gallon
so you're talking about £36
of feed already,
and you can still go back
after they suck the feed down.
And it looks like
they never were fed at all.
They're just starving.
It's nonstop.
So it's just an added cause,
and you're just trying to do the
you have to
make that tough decision of
really isn't worth the money.
The financial costs to try to
save it
or do you just have to walk away
and take your medicine?
This is all beef food.
This will be used for liquid bee
at Man Lake Bee, an egg supply.
They're mixing sugar water
as fast as they can.
And while some bee farmers
file for federal relief,
the greater good charity
is giving away a quarter
ton of pollen substitute
where we have donated meals
to food pantries for humans.
We've donate
and supplies to animal shelters
and now we're donating this bee
substitute to these farmers here
Can't forget the bottom of the f
chain, right?
Can't forget what helps
get all the other food
to the table as well.
But even if their bees recover,
the whole business
depends on the health
of the almond crop in California
now shrinking under megadrought.
If the drought takes out
the almond crop in California
that the whole beekeeping indust
is going to be in trouble.
And and there's no feral bees.
There's no wild bees
can't survive on their own.
He explains that pesticides deve
and invasive pests
have made it impossible
for bees to survive
without deliberate human care.
And if all the beekeepers releas
all of their bees,
every beekeeper in the country,
if they just released
all their bees into the wild,
we estimated bee about two to th
before bees would just collapse.
Bees are the most important farm
They're the most forgotten as we
And that's why we just need
the entire public
to really continue
to get involved in bees.
And a little to beehives
makes a big impact.
They went totally underwater
somehow made it.
In the meantime, all Keith can d
pick up the pieces
and focus on the survivors.
Like the hive
he found drowned inside a water
near Fort Myers Beach.
It's a different feeling
when you have bees walking all o
It's really it's
and nobody's getting stung.
No.
You know, they're doing their th
Maybe they can sense
we're rooting for them, you know
Well, and that's we appreciate t
That's part of the thing.
You have to
you have to treat them with resp
When you get down to it,
the bees are the pillars
to all agriculture ants.
That they're the pillars
to our whole civilization.
Of course, he's a trained beekee
Don't try that at all.
Reaching into a hive, but no sti
They're completely chill
as long as we were.
I brought you some old Florida
bee company, Honey
Orange Blossom and Florida Palme
Here from down there.
This is Jeremy Hamm's company
signing the piece.
I got you some dog. Jalen
coming.
Two jars over there.
I got a third jar for you guys.
You can fight over the cinnamon
That's the best.
But really,
I mean, that's
the thing that scared me
is that we're now in a place
where bees can't live without us
and we can't live without bees.
So we got to do something better
Got to pay attention
to what's happening
in those little busy business pa
I was telling Bill
guys in the break that this is l
what I give to my kids
whenever they're sick
or under the weather.
Like, it's like this natural hea
It's any allergies, it's
an anti-inflammatory. It's.
And they're keeping us alive.
We're feeding them.
They're feeding us,
and it tastes good and it tastes
as a bonus.
A spoon of honey for you in the